para mí realmente es un honor poder
practicar con ustedes y apoyar a jóvenes
que se atreven a hacer cosas diferentes
en esta ciudad y ser partícipe de este
nuevo de este nuevo esfuerzo de todos
pero particularmente en este momento
para mí es aún más importante el tener
la oportunidad de presentar este tema
ante dos de las personas más importantes
de mi vida que son mis hijos que están
aquí con nosotros gracias por estar
conmigo
más que ser una presentación
lo que quiero es practicar con ustedes
es conectarme con ustedes es compartir
lo que yo he aprendido a través de la
vida y tratar de
hacerlo juntos
el responsable eres tú
aceptarlo es una forma de vida
y creo estoy convencido que todos
debemos de aceptar este paradigma
aunque este mensaje es aún más
importante para las nuevas generaciones
vivimos en una sociedad donde cada vez
es más importante lo que parece es en
lugar de lo que eres donde todo mundo le
eche la culpa a todo y a todos de lo que
sucede
donde más importante lo que sucede en
las redes sociales que lo que sucede en
tu vida real
es por eso que el objetivo es invitarlos
a que vivamos a motivarnos a vivir una
vida que valga la pena lo que significa
eso para cada quien no hay una respuesta
exacta
cada quien tiene sus diferentes
preferencias sus diferentes objetivos
lo importante es que seas tú el que está
decidiendo que lo que está pasando con
tu vida
todos tenemos historias vivencias
experiencias que de alguna manera nos
han marcado para bien o para mal y mucha
gente se escuda en lo que le pasó cuando
era niño en lo que está sucediendo en la
economía lo que está pasando en el
entorno incluso está el clima
estoy convencido que todos y cada uno de
nosotros tenemos nuestra vida en
nuestras manos que depende de nosotros
lo que suceda
tal vez no tenemos el control de todo
sucederán cosas que están fuera de su
alcance lo que sí podemos controlar es
cómo reaccionamos ante estas situaciones
accidentes enfermedades crisis
lo importante es que tengamos conciencia
de quiénes somos y hacia dónde vamos en
nuestras acciones
día a día sean dirigidas o siguiendo esa
visión de largo plazo de nuestra propia
vida de nuestra comunidad de nuestra
empresa lo que sí les recomiendo y lo
digo porque yo he cometido una serie de
errores atrás de mi vida es que lo que
hagan la edición que tengan de sonido en
largo plazo lo hagan basados en ciertos
principios básicos
cada quien podrá escoger los suyos yo
les quiero compartir los que he
compartido con mi gente con mi familia
con la gente con la que colabora la
empresa
el primero que yo aplico o que intentó
aplicar en la integridad
no esa entidad
tampoco estamos hablando de que nunca
hacemos
cosas
como están errores etcétera lo
importante es mi punto de vista es ser
congruentes entre el decir y el hacer
que puedas platicarle a tus hijos lo que
haces que puedas dormir tranquilo en la
noche sabiendo que cometiste errores
policies t de acuerdo a lo que eres que
no se aparentan dos cosas que no son
el segundo valor que yo busco intentó
aplicar día a día en mi vida en la
excelencia
el tratar siempre de dar tu mejor
esfuerzo si siempre lo haces
excelencia nunca lo vas a lograr
pero eventualmente conseguirás salir
adelante
aplicar la excelencia no solamente en el
trabajo también en tus relaciones
personales en tu vida personal en tu
cuidado en lo que comes en cómo duermes
en etcétera
el tratar de siempre hacer las cosas lo
mejor posible te dará resultados
positivos en el largo plazo tal vez no
en el primer día pero si definitivamente
en el largo plazo
y eso me voy al tercer valor
qué es la constancia
no hay nada que valga la pena
prácticamente nada que valga la pena que
lo puedas conseguir de un día para otro
y volvemos a lo que estamos viviendo en
esta sociedad esta buscamos la
gratificación inmediata
buscamos el resultado rápido el
sentirnos bien ahorita cuando lo que
realmente nos va a dar cuando eso es
posible y cuando lo que realmente nos va
a permitir lograr el objetivo es ser
constantes trabajar todos los días
impulsarnos todos los días caernos y
levantarnos y seguir luchando por lo que
queremos
y eventualmente lo vamos a lograr
el cuarto valor
es trabajo en equipo
los seres humanos
somos seres de comunidad salvo contadas
excepciones que les gustan ser ermitaños
y estar completamente separados en las
comunidades somos gentes que tenemos que
estar parte de un grupo que tenemos que
para poder ser felices nuestra familia
nuestra ciudad nuestro barrio nuestra
empresa
pero para eso tenemos que entender que
eso es dejar de ser egoístas y compartir
lo que somos y lo que hacemos y hacer
nuestro cachito nuestro pedacito lo que
tenemos que hacer nosotros para que la
comunidad en general funcione
siempre estamos diciendo y esperando que
venga alguien más a hacer las cosas
si quisiéramos tener realmente nuestra
ciudad limpia no tenemos que esperar a
que venga la compañía de limpieza a
barrer nuestra calle si cada quien va
riera su banqueta mañana tendríamos un
nuevo largo completamente limpio y eso
es lo que me refiero que cada quien haga
su parte y no espera que el imas venga a
ser lo suyo
el quinto valor valga la redundancia
es el valor
el atrevernos por su felicito a los
muchachos de este evento atreverse a
hacer las cosas atreverse a decir las
cosas atreverse a luchar por algo
no estás sentados esperando o con miedo
el miedo nada más te paraliza el que no
tira gol
no mete gol
los invito a que tengan ese valor de
impulsarse de atreverse de hacer si se
van a equivocar
pero van a aprender global hombre
intentar y eventualmente les va a salir
y por último
para mí es sumamente importante este
valor porque es el que aglomera todo es
la pasión el sentir las cosas el que tú
realmente estés convencido y disfrutando
lo que estás haciendo
con pasión con convicción
va a ser una persona íntegra va a ser
una persona excelente hace una persona
constante vas a tener el valor de hacer
las cosas y vas a ser capaz de trabajar
en equipo pero tienes que sentir que la
sangre te hierve por lo que estás
haciendo no es solamente
hacerlo por hacerlo si no lo quieres
hacer algo es preferible no hacerlo si
no estás comprometido con lo que vas a
hacer estoy feliz y no se vale decir no
de hecho es muy importante saber decir
no si no te pierdes pero es importante
que apliquemos principios a lo que
hacemos que tenemos una visión clara
hacia dónde queremos ir nosotros cada
quien en nuestra vida en nuestra
comunidad en nuestra empresa y que lo
apliquemos valores que compartamos eso
los que yo aplico los que intento seguir
ustedes pueden escoger los suyos pero es
importante que los definan y que los
vivan porque la medida que se junten
como personas que compartan los mismos
valores van a poder avanzar y ser
felices
sino simplemente están pagando
estamos estaríamos vagando por el mar
sin saber a qué se hacia qué puerto
vamos
definitivamente no podemos cambiar al
mundo en un día
hay muchas cosas con las cuales no
estamos de acuerdo y no podemos ser
ante muchas cosas de ellas lo que sí
podemos hacer
es el día de hoy decidir enfocarnos en
nosotros
en cambiarnos nosotros y hacer que las
cosas sucedan con nosotros y en la
medida que decidamos nosotros mismos
vivir una vida plena sana y feliz
nosotros
y cada uno de ustedes yo
vamos a tener un impacto en la gente que
nos rodea en nuestra vida no pasará
sin ser sin dejar una huella perdurable
en la gente que está junto a nosotros y
de esta manera poco a poco vamos a ir
cambiando el mundo siéndolo como
realmente queremos que sea
a mí una un mensaje en una película que
vi cuando tenía como 23 años
muchos de los presentes aquí no yo creo
que no había ni nacido se llama corazón
valiente
ya casi el final
el protagonista principal el personaje
de la de la película va a ser
digo pierde la guerra
y le dan una salida fácil que era
suicidarse
en ese momento perdería el precisamente
todo lo que estaba luchando y lo que
contestó en los momentos mejor
impactados entonces porque él estoy
convencido que es real
y dice todos los hombres mueren
más no todos los hombres viven realmente
a partir de ahí bien o mal
digo no sé si lo he logrado pero lo
estoy intentando
es tratado hacer eso de vivir la vida
realmente vivir la vida realmente yo
tomar las decisiones haciendo a mi vida
tratar de influenciar en la gente que
está junto conmigo tratar de participar
en mi comunidad para tener un mundo
mejor
en lo que podemos alcanzar
definitivamente
les invito
a no ver la vida como es
a luchar
por la vida como debiera ser
y definitivamente
los invito a aceptar
con todo lo que esto conlleva que el
responsable de lo que suceda en tu vida
eres tú y nadie más que tú muchísimas
gracias
[Aplausos]